sur les cent mille façons de tuer khaliq
la plus dangereuse je sais le coup de
fusil les cent mille façons de tuer un
homme
une chanson satirique du poète félix
leclerc qui jette un regard critique sur
l'assurance emploi c'est cette chanson
qu'une enseignante d'art dramatique de
l'école saint enfant jésus a choisi de
présenter à des élèves de 3e et 4e année
mais après qu'un parent est jugé ce
choix inapproprié
elle a préféré demander aux élèves de
jeter leur copie du texte au recyclage
parce que c'est un parent parmi tant
d'autres une décision qui fait réagir
des autres parents d'élèves qui
fréquentent l'école des livres là il ya
un homme qui sont plus et en plus c'est
plus cruel que ce que je me dis ça fait
partie de la vie jusqu'au premier
ministre du québec ça pas de punch à
l'écouté le gie lu le texte l'objet je
vois pas de problème avec ce texte
claude l'enseignant de l'enseignante
durée estime ce spécialiste de l'oeuvre
de félix leclerc est aussi d'avis que le
choix du texte était appropriée
c'est une chanson qui ont une dimension
théâtrale il voit dans la décision de
retirer la chanson un précédent
dangereux en chansons autant québécois
c'est en chanson francophone des
chansons qui soulève des difficultés
d'autres moral est haute
il y en aura beaucoup donc si on
commence à faire le tri de cette façon
là on n'en finira plus la commission
scolaire de montréal n'a pas répondu à
nos demandes refusées pour l'alliance
des professeurs de montréal
cet événement est le symptôme d'un
problème beaucoup plus grand il ya
beaucoup de directions mais qu elle pas
tout mais on a beaucoup qui ont ouvert
la porte a justement répondre à des
besoins mais j'aurai besoin plus à des
demandes spéciales de parents mais on a
déclar de 25 30
donc ça finit par être un trait du seul
à gérer et de rsa empiète sur notre
autonomie professionnelle
selon elle c'est peut-être une des cent
mille raisons pour lesquelles les
enseignants préfèrent parfois choisir
leur combat ils si mathieu papillon
radio canada montréal